a world-renowned wine critic is on a
mission to teach people that wine is for
everyone Antonio galuna is known for
covering the top wine regions worldwide
in 2013 he started a go-to website for
wine lovers Venice has readers in more
than 90 countries the platform includes
wine reviews profiles of drinking
destinations and vineyard maps colonias
mobile app delectable helps people learn
about wine it's offering a premium
subscription starting today and for
$5.99 a month it lets users access
nearly 250,000 expert reviews by
scanning a wine label on their phone
wine shoppers can also search for
reviews at delectable kiosks in 365 by
Whole Foods stores the kiosks will
expand to more Whole Foods locations
this year antonio colonia is with us
good morning morning thanks for being on
the show absolutely so tell us about the
app so delectable which is the Instagram
of wine and has over 5 million user
reviews for the first time is going to
offer the ability to also have the
expert critic reviews from our wine
publication Venice all seamlessly
available in one digital app and that is
just tremendous news for wine lovers
because you will have all of that
together and what if I can get it for
free Antonio from those 5 million user
reviews why would I want to pay $5.99
well you have the options you have the
free version which is free and improved
yes and then if you want to have the
expert reviews from critics like me who
spend all of our time traveling and
visiting vineyards all over the world
then that's $5.99 a month you kind of
like to Anna Wintour of like she's Anna
Wintour fashion your sort of like the
Anna Wintour of wines because you take
the wine business very very seriously
yes because you said you the way you
look at it wine is for everybody do you
think the wine you drink determines the
personality does that say something
about your personality of course it does
sort of you know what's wearing or yeah
absolutely how's that well you know if
you like zippy albariño you're probably
pretty optimistic and like fresh crisp
wines or Cabernet Sauvignon is bolder
wine probably says something about your
your personality absolutely it's
interesting he's saying that because I
told them that I liked albariño oh did
you
[Music]
still till still buy wine based on the
label that's right that must drive you
crazy oh you know it's a start you know
basically when I walk into a restaurant
I want to see a wine on every table you
do that yeah and our mission with Venice
and delectable is to touch every single
person in the world who has an interest
in wine so if you start by just shopping
by the label that's fine but an applic
delectable can take you to the next
level by giving you all of that
information again it's 5,000 million 5
million user reviews there's an
extraordinary amount of information and
that just informs a consumer even more
and as you mentioned we've got this new
partnership with Whole Foods and you
take what you do there with the
delectable kiosks cuz you take a bottle
you take it to the kiosk scan it you
will get the delectable user review
alongside with curated content from
Whole Foods like recipes for example and
that just means that shopping for wine
has never been easier well that's a good
idea yeah I think you know you know for
many amateurs they have a wine that they
like but they'd like to learn more about
which wine might taste good with what
types of foods you're trying to provide
that information absolutely
yeah it's all about education and
outreach what is your expert opinion on
Boone's Farm Strawberry Hill because
that's all I know from high school I
know because I don't drink I was talking
about I don't drink so on that
experience in high school and it sort of
scarred me for life but that's all I
remember is brewing farm strawberry oh
but it's been said that rosy is having a
moment that it's the wine of the people
what does that mean and why is rosy
having a moment well I think there's two
things one there's more roses than ever
before a lot of them are absolutely
delicious people are discovering that
this is the style of wine that you don't
have to just drink in the summer you can
drink it year-round and then there's
another thing which is those wines are
really affordable you know one of the
big trends in wine is that it's just
never been a better time to be a wine
consumer because there's so many choices
from all over the world of wines that
are affordable rose' fits neatly into
that category and that's those are two
of the reasons why it's having it was
interesting to see that millenials drink
about 17 percent of the wine in the u.s.
that's huge right it's actually larger
are our stats show that Millennials last
year accounted for 42 percent of the
volume of wine consumed in the United
States and women
account for about half of that about
half of the wine women or women drink
more women drink wine than men under 30
into 30 okay yeah it's 50% women and
then men you know we're always a little
bit later to catch up after 30 it evens
out I don't know any women that don't
that drink a lot of wine no I don't know
any none what you talking about noir
O'Donnell everybody that works empirical
at Strawberry Hill all over the newsroom
exactly three a cow Antonio Golani thank
you very much good job rubbing up what
you're doing great thank you a lot of
wine lovers will appreciate this